من عمان الى العراق زينب المشاط وعن
ارتفاع حالات العنف الاسري في العراق زينب
عاده هي في اربيل اكثر
الجرائم التي ترتكب كعنف ولكن في عموم
العراق
اما في المركز والمحافظات الاخرى فاكثر
حالات العنف تكون ضد النساء طبعا الاسبوع
الماضي في نهايه الاسبوع الماضي شاهد
العراق اكثر من حاله عنف اسري كان من
ابرزها لفتاه قامت بقتل والدتها طبعا بطلب
من الام بحسب المصادر الامنيه التي اثبتت
ان الام هي منحت الفتاه الذات الرابعه عشر
من عمرها
مسدسا وطلبت منها ان تقتلها بسبب سوء
الاوضاع المعيشيه حاله اخرى ايضا غريبه هي
بالبدايه كانت مسجله كحاله انتحار في
محافظه بابل لكن فيما بعد اثبت التحقيق ان
رجل كان يعني مخمورا وقام باضرام النار
بزوجته وقتلها وحين الرجل طبعا الى القضاء
وفق الماده 455
وذلك بسبب عدم وجود قوانين خاصه للعنف
الاسري باختصار شديد بدنا نحكي عن الموضوع
الثاني ولكن هل هناك اسباب محدده زينب ليش
ارتفعت حالات العنف الاسري في الفتره
الاخيره باختصار
[تصفيق]
الف حاله عنف اسري وسبب هو بعدم تفعيل
قانون العنف الاسري رغم انه الشيطان
ومنظمات المجتمع المدني تضغط على البرلمان
لتشريع هذا القانون يبدو لنتحدث عن
الموضوع الاخر الذي هو قد يكون سبب
بسبب العنف رحل بطل القصه الثانيه الى
الغابات ولجا الى الغابات وترك المدن عن
شاب عراقي في اقليم كردستان يدعى عمران
انتشر على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بانه
ترك المدينه وذهب للعيش في الغابات طبعا
المروجون لقصه عمران ذكر وان عمران يرتدي
الملابس البدائيه ويتناول يصطاد الحيوانات
ويتناولها نيه اعترض طبعا المتابعون على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي على ان عمران
يتناول الحيوانات لكنهم لم يعترضوا على
مغادرته للمدينه ولجوئه الى الغابات على
اعتبار ان المدن بحسب احد المعلقين المدن
اصبحت غابات اكثر عنفا من غابات الطبيعه
وانا هنا يعني اتساءل يا عادل وراويه هل
اذا انتقل الانسان الى او البشريون اذا
انتقلوا الى الغابات هل الغابات تخفف من
شده عنفهم ام ستتحول الغابات الى مدن الخل
الواحد ينشغل بنفسه ما ينشغل بالاخرين
والله يا زينب عايش معه يمكن ما في حدا
يكون عنيف مع الحيوانات
من العراق وين نروح الغابات عندنا حر ما
نقدر اصلا
متابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقص
ص اقياد والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات